convié croyez vous qu'il y ait deux
papas plus jeunes et autres aux échos
notez bien sur vos droits au hasard
parce que claude a passé ils ont manqué
[Musique]
je suis très contente de mes confitures
vins confitures défendu pâte à tarte
j'ai pris un petit pot vite pour y
mettre ma colle au déconfiture
je vais les cacher sinon il n'y en aura
plus ce soir je vais t'aider
[Musique]
personne à moi la confiture les oubliés
maccoll ici je ne pense à rien moi
[Musique]
oui tu auras une bonne surprise ce soir
à gratot quand tu aimes bovine lequel
otazu tu fais la tête à cause des
confitures j'habite en donner un peu
vain bien fait pour toi tu n'en veux pas
tu as envie à tort les fameux qu'est ce
que tu dis je vais en ville
encore que veux-tu je n'ai plus de
rouges à lèvres
veux tu que je te rapporte à l'illustré
pâte azur paca zut
mais qu'est ce qui lie la mathieu book
assez bizarre d'habitude il ne boude
jamais mais tu as raison
pourvu qu'ils ne soient pas malades
colas cette année cole instantanée de me
plaindre et au marchand de couleurs
ça sent la fraise
on en mangerait
c'est à cloud vient voir pâte à zut j'ai
boudé pâte à tarte et inquiète mais ne
boude pas il vous fait marchés n'ont
même pas voulu
notons qu'en tous préféré bon ça suffit
maintenant
la plaisanterie a assez duré une bonne
fée si au moins il pleura pour quelque
chose
il court bien vite pour un malade je ne
voudrais pas j'ai mangé de la colle
nacaso laver la bouche avec de l'eau
chaude
c'est la première fois que tu fais la
boustifaille news mans les dents part je
parle je parle comme je suis kotok
parker mouscron pape apporte mon gâteau
avec tout un grand pot de confiture
[Rires]